good good alright hello everybody and
thank you for sticking around I know
it's been a really long conference but
you could just like had your brains
crammed full of awesome stats and
probabilistic goodness and we are hoping
to continue that now and my name is
Mitzi Morris I'm a member of the stand
development team I work up at Columbia
with Andrew Gelman and I am going to
talk about Bayesian inference for you
with you to you and so let's get some
general remarks in review and what we're
going to talk about is multilevel
regression models in stan and then ways
to evaluate infants so Stan how many of
you are using Stan okay good
how many of you would like to use ten
how many of you have heard of still
great okay this is better um great so
Stan is named after Stanislaw ulam who
originated Monte Carlo estimation so
we'll start with the story and the story
is how Stanislaw ulam came up with the
Monte Carlo estimation technique which
is that he was working at Los Alamos on
the Manhattan Project and he got sick so
they sent him to the hospital and in
those days if you're in the hospital and
you're working on a super highly
classified top-secret project you do not
get to bpn back to the lab so he had
nothing to do in his hotel room but play
solitaire and as a statistician he
looked at solitaire the game and said
well what are my chances if I have a
perfectly shuffled deck of cards and I
deal myself out the solitaire game what
are my chances of winning
um and so from probability theory you
should be able to start having 50 to
choose 151 choose 2 bla bla bla for all
of your stuff and he realized that he
just couldn't figure out what that big
combinatorics was and this was
distressing because he thought he should
be able to do it and in the end he just
played games of solitaire over and over
and over again and counted up the number
that he won and the number that he lost
and at the end he had an estimate of his
chances of winning any random game of
solitaire from a well shuffled deck and
so that is essentially estimation by
simulation you simulate a whole bunch of
times and that set of simulations are
your sample and at the end you look at
your sample and you compute over the
sample and answer the questions that you
want to answer using the proportional
information that's present in your
sample ok so that's that's it that's
Monte Carlo methods and they're called
Monte Carlo methods because there's a
famous casino in Monte Carlo where you
go gambling and so everything there is
random so it's all about randomness Stan
is a probabilistic programming language
so it's a domain-specific programming
language and what you are doing in the
Stan language when you write us Stan
program is you are expressing the total
joint probability of all the parameters
in your model so we're going to get to
that and we'll see lots of examples Stan
uses the Stan Nuts HMC sampler which
does Monte Carlo Markov chain Monte
Carlo sampling and this is what sort of
took Stan and they were original there
were already probabilistic programming
languages using Bayesian techniques bugs
and Jags Stan is an order of magnitude
more powerful
then they are precisely because the
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo that's the H MC
in h MC Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is a
very efficient way of doing this
simulation these random jumps around
posterior probability density and it
works really well when you're in super
high dimensions and by super high
dimensions I mean you know more than
three or four more than ten definitely
more than ten but think about what
you're doing in any given day when
you're trying to answer some kind of
questions about your data you're usually
trying to get all these features and if
you're doing something like natural
language the amount of features you have
are very very very big even if you're
just collecting information about your
population about your users you've
probably got a dozen features a hundred
features that's a very high dimensional
space each feature is adding a dimension
and these make things very challenging
usually there's a lot of correlations
between different features in your data
and this is going to be difficult to
compute so the Stan Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo method does a very efficient job
of giving you a representative sample
from your complicated posterior space
complicated geometry space of the the
probability of all of your parameters so
and Stan has been around for about six
or seven years now and almost all of the
people who were originally using Stan
were people who are working in are so
the our ecosystem for Stan is very very
rich and I started working on a Python
interface to Stan in January of this
year which were calling commands
hi and because I think that you know
people in the Python community should be
using Stan and should be doing Bayesian
data analysis and actually I don't care
if you use Stan but I do want you to use
Bayesian data analysis and Stan is open
source and command Stan PI is BSD
licensed and what we're talking about
today is multi-level modeling it's a
kind of regression modeling it's what
you want to do and as Kim was talking
about there's this notion of pooling
we're going to see exactly how pooling
works and what we mean by pooling
information and there are a lot of names
for these so and there's also a blog
statistical modeling causal inference in
social science and Bob carpenter put up
a post one day about all the names for
hierarchical and multi-level modeling
and it's a really nice post because he
gives you insight on all these names
just exactly what that group of people
meant when they decided to build their
multi-level model and why they called it
named it the way they did and how it
differs from everybody else so what you
find in the domain of science is that
every group was trying to solve a
problem they they consulted their
statistician they came up with really
really really great techniques that are
pretty much the same thing as what they
came up with the lab down the hall and
they all published and they all
published independently so pretty much
every model that you want to use for
your data has been developed by somebody
else for their data and it's just the
challenge of finding them and
communicating is really difficult and
that's what makes working on stands so
much fun because our user base spans the
gamut of every single kind of user
anybody who's got data is talking to
each other on the forums and we're all
learning from each other
statistical inference we learn about
unknown or unobserved quantities of a
process from the data generated by that
quantum process so what we're doing in
contrast to machine learning especially
those of you who are like gotta do some
got to do some deep belief Nets got to
do some deep learning that's a really
really really great and there are many
many many cases where that's really the
best thing you can do and you should go
ahead and do it but there are also cases
where you're not going to be able to
make that fly in which case you would be
well-served by looking into stan and
what we're doing when we're doing
Bayesian modeling is we're trying to do
a kind of a white box model we care
about your data generating process and
what we're going to do with your
generated data is we're going to try to
build a model and work backwards from
the data to find out more about your
model especially when the parameters in
your model are actionable items so
that's really for a policymaker
or for a business decision maker or for
a scientist you care about what those
parameters are because those are the
things you can change and so by having a
model where all the parameters are
clearly labeled they're giving you a
bunch of levers a bunch of dials on your
process and you can tune them and tweak
them and then ask yourself what's going
to happen and that's generally what
people want to do so that's why Bayesian
methods and Bayesian models are really
really the way to go and the Bayesian
workflow is one where you spend some
time thinking about the model thinking
about the data generating process and
you don't need to worry that much about
your distributions your math you're
asking yourself you know what are the
dependencies how are things related to
each other and especially from
multi-level model
you want to know what things are nested
inside of each other is there
interesting structure in the data that's
coming in that should be reflected in
the model that you're developing once
you've got your model then you're going
to use a tool like Stan to do the
estimation that's just that's just you
know taking some something down off the
shelf and running your data through it
to get an answer what you care about is
afterwards you don't just take that
answer and run you sit back and you look
at that answer and you interrogate that
answer and you say hey wait is this
really what I expect given what I know
about the world because the other thing
that Bayesian x' this like historical
bayesian frequentist debate is all about
not using not putting your thumb on the
scale right Bayesian czar putting their
thumb on the scale well okay so what
it's not like everybody let me let me
let me let me try to make that sound
less defensive we're using what we know
about the world and no matter how you
build your model you're cooking in what
you know you're cooking your
expectations into your model so we're
being honest and we're thinking very
hard about what we know and we're going
to ask ourselves is this what I expect
given what I know at every step of the
way and that's really all that's going
on
and what we want to do with this
Bayesian workflow and what the people
who worked on Stan the set of tools
especially this downstream ecosystem of
visualization and model checking are
trying to do is we're we're encouraging
you to develop as many variants of a
model as you need to give yourself the
answers of what's the minimum I can get
away with what's the max
I should be doing playing around with
what you know about the problem you're
trying to solve so it's we're really
trying to facilitate engagement with the
question that you're trying to answer
more than anything else
statistical notation just so we can be
clear and you've seen this a bunch today
right
nothing scary on this slide great then
we'll just go on Bayes theorem
have we seen Bayes theorem tonight
everybody happy with Bayes theorem okay
so let's go over this slide what we're
interested in is we've got the
conditional probability and for Bayesian
the important the important thing that
we're working with is the posterior
probability distribution we've collected
our data we've built our model we've run
our data through our inference engine
what we have at the end is we have a
posterior probability distribution and
that's what we want to work with so in
the slide what's most important is to
notice there is to notice that in this
probability of theta given Y it's the
probability of your parameters given
your data and I started doing statistics
about a dozen years ago and I kept
driving my husband crazy because I would
just you know write down probability of
Y given theta and probability of the
data given Y and my husband's Bob
carpenter
because he developed Stan originally and
he'd be like you can't eat me what it's
confusing okay it really matters it took
me a while to master this so it's okay
if it takes you guys a while to master
this too but we care about the posterior
probability distribution hello my little
thingy here and when we build a stand
model what the steer
is computing is it's computing the total
joint probability density of all of your
parameters and your data all at once and
it's really cool that it's doing this
and when you are writing your model you
are supplying the priors on your
parameters and you are coming up with
your likelihood function this is what
you supply to your stand model when you
develop a stand model or any Bayesian
model and this is what you get and it's
really nice that you've got this
proportional constant because that makes
things go a lot faster any questions on
this one no and the reason that we want
to be Bayesian is that we want to be
able to actually think about our
posterior distribution the probability
of theta given why we want to think
about it as a full probability
distribution so we can get the mean
median mode and crucially the standard
deviation which is what gives us our
uncertainty and there was a woman here
who asked a question about credible
intervals if you're doing Bayesian data
analysis the credible intervals are
whatever boundaries you want to put on
your posterior probability distribution
so you can have the 95% central
confidence interval you can which is two
standard deviations from the mean and
when you have a full credible interval
you can look at the quantiles in that
credible interval you can figure out
whether or not you've got a really
sharply peaked posterior probability
distribution meaning yeah almost all the
time I know that all my data is going to
be here and it's going to look just like
that or you can have a very very broad
shellow sort of a posterior probability
distribution which means you know I'm
not so sure about what I know I know
that it could be you know between 2 & 98
but gosh I really don't know much more
than that and that's really useful
information for you to proceed in any
kind of a decision-making situation so
Monte Carlo simulation what do we mean
by a sample I think what we mean by a
sample is that we've got somewhere in
our back pocket we've got a random
number generator and we're going to be
able to generate quantities random
quantities at will and a classic example
of Monte Carlo simulation is calculating
PI it works really nicely because you
can take you a random number generator
and you can generate numbers between
minus 1 and 1
really easily and if you do that for X Y
points you've now got a rectangle which
has an area of 4 and you have a unit
circle and the area of your unit circle
is PI R squared and then with just a
little bit of algebra you can count all
of the points with a simple mathematical
formula is x squared plus y squared less
than 1 great there in the circle
otherwise they're out of the circle how
many what's the proportion of points in
the circle PI's your answer we're
multiplying it by 4 and so you can do
that in Python and I did that in Python
and I did that in Python a hundred times
and my estimate of Pi was 3.5 which is
kind of a ballpark estimate and then I
did it a little bit longer and I started
to get pretty pretty close you know as
much as I needed to know about pi and it
took more and more time and the point of
this slide is that when you're
using these estimation by simulation
techniques you need a sample and you
only need as big a sample as you need to
get the precision the accuracy that
matters to use so if you don't have a
need for five decimal places of accuracy
you don't have to go there because it'll
take a long time the Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo I said a little bit about
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo I can't say
anything more about Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo and get there in this but if
you're interested I love this paper it's
a really nice and there's a link at the
end of my slides I put a link to this
paper it's a really nice example of how
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo works and it
compares it to Gibbs samplers which some
which some of you might have heard of
and shows why you really really really
want to be using Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
and there are as I mentioned PI MC 3
Edward and pyro are all using
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo so I'm not here
to tell you you have to use Stan I'm
just here to tell you you should let's
go on to linear regression linear
regression is everybody know linear
regression good so we've here's here's
your canonical example you've got just a
simple pair of XY predictors X is your
data why is your observed outcome you
want to create a model of the data
generating process for Y and you're just
going to put weights on your X's so
you're going to figure out where's your
intercept and what is the slope of the
line and now you can draw a line through
your cloud of points that minimizes the
distance from every Y to its Y on the
line so it's a vertical distance and it
works out really nicely in terms of the
square
and when you have a regression model you
are saying that my regression model is
going to fit my data with some amount of
random error and that epsilon is
considered to be random noise
independent random noise so epsilon has
the distribution of normal centered zero
with some unknown variance Sigma that
means that we plug X in as the estimate
of our mean and we use Sigma as our
variance and there we have it a Stan
programs statement which says that our
observed data Y is drawn from a normal
distribution with mean alpha plus beta
times X and variance Sigma so this is
your first example of Stan syntax any
instance int X was developed to look
like bugs syntax or our syntax and I
think there are things in Python where
you might be using the sampling notation
so our first example is Major League
Player batting ability there's a very
detailed case study I generated the PDF
from the case study and it ran to 60
pages it's a great case study and my
goal today is to get you through the
highlights of this so that you can then
dive in and appreciate the goodness in
this case study and we're looking at
baseball players
I mean statistics in baseball are just
like you know beans and cornbread what
we've got here are data for Major League
Baseball players this is based on a
study case study that was done by
somebody named Brad Efron bootstrap Brad
if you've used the bootstrap technique
Efrain and Morris and he's not related
to me but you know
it's too bad and what they did was they
looked at the 1975 major league baseball
season cheery picked a couple of
interesting cases of you know good
players and not-so-good players and they
looked at their first 45 at-bats and
then they had the stats on the rest of
the season and there are three ways that
we can look at deciding what the
predictions we should make about the
number of hits that a player gets in a
certain number of it bets we can say
that all players are exactly alike and
so all we need to do is estimate average
player ability we can say that all
players are snowflakes they're very
special and each player gets his own
model which you guys might be doing in
some of your applications right your
every stock has its own model or
something or you can try to do the multi
level thing which is what everybody
really really wants to do which is to
say that okay we have a general
population of baseball players if you're
a major league baseball player you
probably fit this profile and we know
something in general about what our
Major League Baseball players look like
and we know that players differ from
Player to Player so we have what are the
group level effects and the individual
or a random effects and so that's what
our our multi-level model is going to do
for you and then we're going to show you
what the results of setting up these
three models look like so to model
player batting ability we're using a
binomial distribution that is to say we
have a number of at-bats and during that
number of at-bats our player got a
certain number of hits so that is the
distribution on the bottom hello laser
pointer so we're going to calculate the
probability of say getting 18 hits
in your first 45 at-bats given that you
have an ability theta and this theta is
comes from your Bernoulli from your coin
flip model you've got a binary out huh
come you get up to bat either you get a
hit or you don't get a hit here are our
players these are the top players and
the bottom players in this 18 player
example data set Roberto Clemente in his
first 45 at-bats in the 1975 Major
League Baseball season got 18 hits which
would give him a batting average of 400
are there any baseball fans here okay so
what major league baseball player ever
got had a 400 average Ted Williams yes
you get a spin state that one yeah so we
don't really I mean Roberto Clemente
don't get me wrong he's great but do we
really think that he had a 400 batting
average I don't know about it and this
leads to the next question is why did
they use 45 at-bats well he probably
didn't get a hit on they at bat number
46 or at bat number 47 because then they
would have gone up to 50 you know so
when you get your data you should
interrogate your data from the get-go in
any case this is the example we're
working with and if we plot so this plot
is showing you the individual batting
averages and the average batting
averages so these are your two choices
for models number one and models number
two and this is a little bit more a
quick review of the binomial
distribution what's cool about the
binomial distribution is it is giving
you a integer value output so this is
for this distribution we don't have any
information there is no getting a hit
14.5 right you
you get 14 hits you can get 15 hits and
if you had a 400 batting average you in
45 at-bats might only get 11 or 12 that
is within the the credible interval and
you might you might get 24 and when you
think about this you begin to understand
when you're watching the World Series
and every time a player did it got a
really good hit god I got lucky really
it's pretty random so yeah and what
we're going to do is we're going to show
you some stand models and I'm going to
try to go as quickly as I can through
stand because I don't want to get bogged
down in teaching you how to write Stan
programs because it's learning another
programming language but I will say that
Stan as a programming language has a
syntax which is not pythonic I'm sorry
your variables are strongly typed your
blocks are enclosed by curly braces you
have orderid blocks and the named blocks
are calling out the important parts of
your Stan program this is a really
really cool feature of Stan but it's a
good thing and a bad thing it does make
you think about what is my data and what
are my parameters at the same time when
you're writing your Stan model it
doesn't always make it that easy to see
the data generating process story told
that cleanly and so there's a lot of
talk in the Stan community about how
we're going to change the Stan language
and possibly make Stan programs
different too right so another reason
for not going into stand right now and
that's pretty much all you need to know
about stan syntax and again in a Stan
program you declare all of your
parameters in a special named parameters
block and then in the model block the
model block is where the Stan program
computes the joint log probability
density of
parameters and the data so the model
blocks special parameters blocks special
data block also special here is a
multi-level model in Stan it's taken
directly from the case study so we have
a parameter Phi which is the population
chance of success so that looks like our
Bernoulli Phi if you compare it to you
here in the all players are all alike we
call that Phi that's your average player
ability and for all different players we
have a vector of parameters theta so
here in the multi-level model we have
this Phi and we have this theta and we
have a Kappa which is prior on our prior
and the case study goes into why this
particular parameter sation was chosen
and it's very interesting to follow
because there are some difficulties with
this parameterization this is not that
easy to fit and you could make your
model more efficient by Reaper ammeter
izing which is again a very important
part of building model that you're going
to drop into a production workflow it's
got to compute in real time so in this
model here we put we put a hyper prior
on our prior and then we compute our
prior and our likelihood know if this is
our likelihood this is our prior this is
a hyper prior okay what I said and so
when we fit this model we see that the
orange is the outcome of using the
multi-level model
and what it does is it smooths out our
estimates it lets us say that the best
players are better than the worst
players or not-so-hot players but
they're more alike than we thought they
were so in this visualization the very
last bar here on the right is the
complete pooling model so it's not
really a player but I put it in that way
instead of drawing the average line
across okay would you like to see how
this works or should I go on to the next
soccer model let's see how it works so
I've put the I put the links to these
notebooks and all of this data up on the
stand website and I post it in the
select general select channel so you can
download these slides and and this data
set this is the data set and here's the
link to the case study for you so we're
going to use command stand PI which is a
lightweight wrapper around commands 10
which is the command line interface to
the stand inference engine so we'll just
make sure that we're using Stan and oh
look we're using the very latest
commenced in 221 here are our baseball
players and yep that's the data and then
we're going to plot
yeah and this is just the plot that I
created to show you so this is using oh
no wait this is just plotting the data
right right right right so what we have
to do for command Stan PI is we're going
to munch out the data that we want to
feed into our model we're just munching
the data here so we're going to feed in
a data dictionary and what's going to be
in that data dictionary are the the
names of all the variables that are in
the data block of the model and just for
fun this is how I computed the binomial
distribution which was in that plot we
looked at that's not really very
interesting for what we're doing now so
now we're actually going to go through
commenced in and we are going to we
first we're going to declare our model
and once we've declared the model it's a
it's a disk it's it's a file on disk we
can examine what that is so we'll print
out the code for the model then we're
going to compile the model and then
we're going to do the fit and then we're
going to get the summary of how well the
model fits the data
okay so bombs away
and you can see that it is right now
compiling the model while we admire the
model and it's going to take about 30
seconds well it took much longer to
compile that model than it did to run
for chance
so sampler chains are we familiar with
sampler chains okay we're doing Markov
chain Monte Carlo
so what command Stan PI is doing is its
firing off for parallel processes where
the stand model is starting and it's
taking the data and it's doing this mark
in Monte Carlo so that's a chain and
it's giving you a sample so the reason
we want to run multiple chains in
parallel is not that we care about
whether or not they're parallel but when
we're done we want to compare all the
chains against each other because we've
got this Hamiltonian that's jumping
around in this complicated posterior
space and if you have coated your model
and made a mistake somewhere along the
way or if you just have the wrong model
or if you've just really done something
super stupid
your sampler will get stuck so what you
want to see if you've got a good if
you've got a model that is well
conditioned appropriate for your data
you want to be able to know that
whenever you fired up a chain that
you've got this nice super random
behavior and so you're going to compare
a bunch of chains against each other and
you're going to look for the absence of
any patterns whatsoever
within chains or across chains and if
you get that behavior then you feel like
okay I've got the proper conditions for
me to reason about this sample the
sample truly is a random sample it's
generated from a process it's a Ghatak
it's reversible it is all these good
things I actually can trust that I've
now got a proper sample from my
posterior distribution because if you
don't have if you don't if your model
hasn't converged and you got a sample
you've got a sample from crap it doesn't
mean anything you cannot use this data
so we like this data because this
actually is correct and then we've got
all these drawers we've actually got
four thousand drawers in our sample from
the posterior now we can compute
statistics over them and we see what's
most important here is that we have Phi
is 270 0.27 so we're saying that your
your average baseball player has a 270
average fine works yeah that's pretty
good
and now we're going to do exactly the
same thing just to show you that we can
do it twice and this is the second model
again it's taking a little bit of time
to compile and in this model we're just
going to yep there goes and now what
we've got is we've got estimates for
every player so player number one is
Roberto Clemente in the data we saw that
he had 400 batting average we've been
doing a taking a random sample and in
our random sample we said well really
the 50 percent quantile is at 400 and
for some reason it's telling me the mean
is it for it Oh point for one but that's
because I round it to two places so
they're probably much closer critically
what you really want to know is dude my
model converge this is the R hat
statistic which is making sure that all
your chains have mixed and are perfectly
random yep my model converged our hat
has to be one or 1.0 if it's one point
one no good and what we see is we have
the number of effective samples in our
sample oh no this is the number of
effective samples per second this is how
fast how efficient our computation is
this is the number of effective samples
which is pretty cool because we ran
4,000 draws but there was anti
correlation so our sample actually is
giving us information more information
than than we thought we could squeeze
out of 4,000 draws we're actually
getting the equivalent of 10,000 draws
from from the posterior which is really
cool and then finally we get the the
model here the simple hierarchical model
which is a little bit more complicated
in terms of the amount of code like it's
got like six more lines of code and it
takes the same amount of time to compile
and it fits beautifully and now we've
got estimates for for our group level
predictor 270 is our average major
league baseball players batting ability
we've got this campus score that's the
hyper Pryor and we've got theta for
Roberto Clemente and we think Roberto
Clemente has actually got about in 320
batting average given what we've seen
and what we know which is still like
really super good and so as I said this
model was difficult to fit what you
might notice here is that I added this
parameter adapt Delta to my sampling
statement that meant go a little slower
take a little bit more time because we
know this model is is not going to do
the right thing and here if I say
diagnosed I get these Diagnostics and
Wow yeah see still mmm not good we got
some we got some divergences so maybe I
should actually up the adapt Delta you
should actually read the case study to
go deeper into the problems with this
model and finally we do some
visualization and voila that's it okay
questions yeah and while we're doing
questions it's been a really long day so
I brought a chocolate for all of you in
case here
[Music]
well that's what hierarchical models are
can you pass this around you know I mean
overfitting well the the regularization
is the same thing as as putting a group
level effect on your data and you can
over fit this model I don't think is
over fitting the data because it's it's
pretty I mean over fitting the data
would mean that we would like crank up
the priors so that we would start in the
right place you can always build a model
to over fit your data yes
this model is pretty general but if you
don't have enough data then maybe you
shouldn't you know really consider these
parameters to be what you want it reason
with does ends your question yeah well
that that's the that gets back to the
whole Bayesian workflow but I mean oops
that gets back to the whole Bayesian
workflow when you're you're
interrogating your fit afterwards you do
want to know how sensitive are you to
outliers so you would take your fitted
model and this is where replication
comes in so we're gonna see that in the
next example so just keep that question
in the back of your mind okay yes yes
yeah sure
yes well Kannan no I didn't know about
that what a great question
christine has auto-da-fé stands
auto-da-fé libraries built in c++ so
stan implemented its own auto-da-fé
library and it is really seriously fast
so Kim was talking about Auto grad the
thing of it is is that when you're
setting up that automatic
differentiation how you how you evaluate
you are how you evaluate those functions
how you set up the calculation of the
gradient you should do it in a super
smart way so you should figure out which
steps are going to be computed over and
over again and how you make sure that
everything is memory local and you do it
out the wazoo so stan is built on a very
high performance C++ automatic
differentiation library and Stan was
built to be fast because Andrew Gelman
is sitting there at every meeting and
all he says is I want my models to fit
faster okay so so we've got people who
really care and they're our boss so
answer your question great okay yes I
was actually going to make you guys are
we okay cuz otherwise I'm gonna make you
get up and do jumping jacks cuz it's
been a long day but you seem to be okay
so that is baseball and the second
example is just it's another example of
setting up a model and looking at the
data and it's the Women's World Cup so
Nietzsche here is like
thank her for this model because she
worked through it and I worked with her
and its really it was a total blast we
did this with the pie ladies why did
that say that anyway okay that was in
the wrong place
this is paired comparison so now we're
no longer talking about individual
baseball players we're talking about
teams and you want to know which team is
gonna win and when you're trying to
figure out which team is going to win
it's often the case that you've never
seen these teams play each other before
or you have seen them play each other
before but you think that you can do a
better job than just like counting how
many times previously you know Ohio
State beat Michigan State or whatever so
what we want to do is we want to
estimate the team ability based on the
match outcome and we are going to use a
linear model to model team ability and
it's going to have group and individual
level characteristics so another multi
level model same thing a little bit more
complicated and what we're interested in
is when we've got a soccer match we're
not going to model it in terms of just
two one and who lost
we're going to model it in terms of the
score differential differential so if if
Germany scores three goals and Nigeria
score scores two goals then the score
differential is one in favor of Germany
and so on and so forth and what we're
looking at here is the visualization we
get to in the end of the model which is
that we're going to estimate our
uncertainty by using replication and
this is called posterior predictive
check so at the end of each what we'll
see it when we get to it
our data our data our xlviii matches up
through the quarterfinals of the Women's
World Cup
there were 24 teams and everybody had
played some amount of the other teams
but not all of them and we have the date
the match list the teams and the scores
we also need to put a prior we don't
know very much about our teams so we're
going to bring in prior information
which is just a single number called the
soccer power index which is on this blog
by nate silver mr. 538 five yeah 5 to 38
he explains what the soccer power index
is so according to the soccer power
index the US was heavily favored u.s.
women's team and then there were going
down to you know 37 so it was a scale
out of a hundred points and what we do
in our stand program again just
reviewing what a stand program looks
like you you set up your your data and
we're going to take in I is going to be
the number of teams and we have a per
team soccer power index and then we have
n matches and what we're doing is this
is you know four parallel arrays that
are essentially a row of a database
table or something like that what you
see here is that you can put bounds on
your strongly typed variables and
statements are executed in order so you
have to declare I before you use it but
you can you know do that nicely in the
transformed data so this is a new data
block the transformed data block is
executed once when the model is
instantiated this is where you can do
work that's only going to be done once
so you can do it sloppily in an
expensive way where you're gonna it but
it allows you critically to take your
data in the way that it comes in from
the wild and then transform it on the
inside of your stand program so that you
don't ever have to worry about
munching your data in the wrong way and
then somehow the model doesn't work with
the next data set so you're going to be
always treating your data the same way
which is really super nice and what
we're doing here is we're standardizing
our soccer power index ratings so that
everything is centered on zero and you
have a variance of one so this is this
is your familiar this is sort of you're
putting your standard your your soccer
power index on the Z scale so we're
calling it the SPI standard and this is
just Stan as a programming language has
four loops and super powerful cool
indexing and a really really really rich
library of built-in statistical
functions and every distribution you
want.we somebody has probably
implemented it and they've probably
implemented a vectorized version of it
too okay and the parameters on our model
are the the per team random effects you
can see that it's per team because it's
got like a vector that's the length of
the number of teams and you can see that
this is group level because it's just a
scalar so these are the two components
of our linear regression model for the
team ability the yeah and in the
transfer and we put variance terms on
the per team variation so we've got a
random effect that random effect has
both the the mean and the variance here
and we have overall
overall noise in our estimate and with
the transformed parameters block is done
at every step of the sampler and it
takes the current estimates of the
parameters and then it runs this
calculation and that's what you use at
the point when you're actually fitting
the model so here the ability is not a
parameter
it's a quantity that we have to use when
we're calculating the other parameters
in the model so by virtue of having this
transformed parameter ability when we
compute with the ability we will be
making the proper inferences about all
of the parameters in the model and we
always put priors on our parameters and
here we're putting priors that are that
are fairly fairly weak priors these are
pretty minimal and somewhere out at the
end I do or did I put it in one of the
previous slides there's there's a link
in here to our prior choice
recommendations but that's an excellent
question
these are the current thinking that
basically these are weakly informative
priors saying that we expect things to
be centered at zero with a certain
amount of variance
[Music]
model would heavens
well the model might have a really hard
time fitting the Diagnostics might not
be good but this is where you are your
model checking would come in but also
your priors reflect what you know about
the world so you should be it's a
question you have to answer but the
stand forms her good place to get advice
and as I say we've got the wiki page
because this there's like tons of tons
of questions around exactly that issue
yeah so yeah so in the generated
quantities block which we haven't seen
yet but we're going to we're going to
replicate our data so now we're going to
produce a sample where at every every
for every estimate of a parameter so for
every draw from the posterior we're
going to use that draw from the
posterior and we're going to run it
through the data generating process
again using the random number generator
to push our uncertainty through to see
what we would get for data if this was
the true parameter everybody follow or
did I can yeah great
so that's what we're doing here we're
using replication and this is going to
give us a handle on our uncertainty that
we can use to draw those credible
interval lines in our our visualization
we could also in our generated
quantities block set things up to do
prediction which is really what we want
to be doing if we were doing prediction
using this model and this regime what we
would need to be doing is we would need
to be do feeding the data that we want
to make predictions about into
the model along with the data that we're
using to actually estimate the
parameters so we would actually have to
in our data block add the indices of the
teams that are going to be in the
semifinals so there's going to be two
semifinals so we've got two teams and we
have to get all the indexes lined up
properly
but then in the generated quantities
black we're going to look at for the two
semifinals we're going to look at each
semifinal game match and we're just
going to say oh okay I've for these
teams now let's just draw from a normal
and shouldn't that be normal orangey
yeah that should be normal orangey yeah
so yeah oh no actually maybe it is maybe
that would work anyway let's do the
ipython notebook and so yeah so this is
the second notebook
oh this notebook right okay so yeah
everything I've said is true we don't
have a lot of data and we have different
players on each team and we do have some
player data so the soccer power index is
going to be a really huge crutch here in
terms of really big prior not a lot of
data and this is the World Cup data that
we've already seen in the slides and
we'll just get it all loaded up and this
is the soccer power index
where you see that these are the top and
the bottom countries in terms of their
things and Stan code and the model is
taking some amount of time to compile so
this is the full program everything
lined up and we've seen all of these
things in the slides in this program
we're not actually doing any prediction
so our inputs are just on the we're just
we're just looking at the quarter final
information and we haven't asked
ourselves who's going to be in the
semifinals or the final so this is just
the model that does replication and so
yeah
so let us fit that and this time I
actually assembled the dictionary that
you want as an on disk file and we will
just run that model and let it fit and
whoa there we go
and all of the things in the model so we
have 24 so all of the variables in the
model now in the parameters transform
parameters and generated quantities
block we have we have a vector alpha we
have alpha beta Sigma Alpha and Sigma Y
so we're going to get all of those guys
in our sample we're also getting the
ability which is what we really care
about and we are also getting a vector
of length 48 for the 48 matches which is
the estimate using all of the team
estimated abilities we're getting an
estimate of what the range of possible
score differentials we could have seen
for that matches
so when we look at the outputs these
guys are all here and and so what we're
going to do is we're going to take those
things and we're going to have to do
some post-processing
to get the visualizations that we want
so first of all we care about what our
estimates of team abilities are and we
think that this is the team ability
expressed as the the their expected
number of goals that they're going to be
scoring in a match because remember when
we have a match outcome we have the
difference in ability between team one
and Team two and that's the met match
outcome so what these numbers are saying
is that the u.s. is probably going to
score one point six four goals and Spain
is probably going to be outscored by a
certain amount and South Korea is really
not going to do well which is surprising
because their soccer power index rating
put them in the middle of the pack so
the data and the prior don't really line
up and the model is actually overriding
the prior and putting South Korea and I
apologize to all the South Koreans I
know they didn't do well I'm sorry and
now we're going to use the posterior
predictive check to to look at the
replicates of the matches so this
replicate is this replicate is showing
you the central confidence interval for
if we redid match number one if we redid
match number one what do we think the
score differential would it be and what
we see here is like a
/ super wide super wide range of
possible outcomes we are not really very
confident about anything which is kind
of appropriate for the situation but you
know in in this in in match number one
it could have gone that you know the the
team number two could have won by as
much as a goal now probably not actually
it could have been a draw or team number
one could have been up by two or three
goals or they could have been up by as
much as five or six goals we really
don't know and so then finally what
we're going to do here is we're going to
plot the plot the make that chart that I
showed you and oh wait no first we're
going to yeah this is just a better
visualization of what I showed you up
above so in France versus South Korea it
could have been a draw in Germany versus
China it was you know definitely Germany
was going to win but still this is a
very wide range of information in our
posterior so we're not really very
certain of anything which is exactly
what we want to know this is why we want
to be Bayesian and we want to get this
posterior probability distribution
because here we know anything can happen
and isn't that great so now finally
we're going to crunch it all together
and we're going to create this beautiful
visualization and I really need to thank
Nietzsche and all the pilotis who put
things together for me on this one what
we're seeing here is the black the red
dot is the actual outcome so if you let
your eye drift down this chart the red
dots should actually be on whole numbers
the black dots are just the midpoint of
our estimate and the full line is our 5
to 95 percent confidence
so as I'm saying this model is not a
great model there's not a lot of data
but it's a model that's comprehensible
questions
okay well in that case we can go to the
final part of this talk and I've
actually got enough time for it what is
this talk over 4:30 okay great perfect
exactly the right amount of time because
I'm not going into much detail on this
last one this is this is getting again
to what cam was talking about when we
want to evaluate our models and evaluate
our inferences so this is sort of like
this is your standard machine learning
setup you've got your model you want to
publish a paper in NURBS or J MLR or
whatever and you're going to take your
model and you want a cowgirl competition
you're going to take your model you
divide it up into your training data and
your test data you use training to infer
the model parameters you plug your
inferred parameters into your data
generating model you use your tend and
then you get your test data inputs to
get your test data outputs and then you
compare your test data outputs to your
gold standard and did you do really well
and isn't that great this is a case
study that's sort of in progress Bob
carpenter put this together in April and
it's showing you why people say you
should be Bayesian this is basically
going through all of the math and all of
the mechanics and making it really super
clear how evaluation works what your
loss function is and why in the end at
the end of the day you really if you
care if it's very very important to get
exactly the right answer you really need
to invest the time in running a Bayesian
regime to
at the full posterior probability
distribution which is not always
necessary right there are plenty of
times when getting a point estimate is
okay and in this case study what he does
is he sets up a logistic regression
model so just a regression model is your
outputs your observed data is a simple
binary indicator yes/no heads tails zero
one lived I bought didn't buy these are
these are the kinds of outcomes that
you're making decisions on and you're
trying to figure out what all of the
parameters that led up to this outcome
are so it's a logistic regression
because it takes things from a binary
output and puts them on a continuous
scale so that you can actually reason
about probabilities in this logistic
regression there are 50 I think 50
predictors and there's a certain amount
of correlation between the 50 predictors
so what we do is we simulate data so we
have known values for all the parameters
plug the known values into the
parameters use our random number
generator to generate that random sample
from the model and then we're going to
test on the model using we're going to
use different inference regimes to fit
the simulated data and then we're going
to check how well does the simulated
data match the way we're going to check
how well did our estimates do in terms
of evaluating the test data on different
metrics of log loss and squared error
and the takeaway message is
that we can always get a lower error
rate if we've got the full Bayesian
posterior it's it's a nice case study it
shows you how to set up the evaluations
and how to recover the parameters and I
didn't go into more detail because I
didn't think that we were gonna have
time to do it but I want you to know
that this is out there and this is
really your your homework assignment
from this talk and from everything I've
told you I hope that you want to go
through and work through this yourself
and I want you to know that you could
use commands 10 pi to do this whole
exercise so in Stan as an inference
engine Stan doesn't just do Bayesian
inference Stan also has optimization
routines so you can do a maximum
likelihood estimate and we have a highly
experimental kids really don't do this
and please if you hurt yourself don't
blame us experimental variational Bayes
inference it's it is what it is
variational base is trying to take your
posterior distribution and find another
distribution that's perhaps
computationally tractable and easier to
compute and it's going to get as close
to what the real unknown posterior
distribution is with the simpler
approximation but then you have a
simpler approximation it's a real
probability distribution so you use the
mean but a point estimate of the mean of
this estimated distribution to be the
mean of your unknown distribution
maximum a-posteriori which is maximum
likelihood penalized maximum likelihood
estimates this is what you're getting
out of just about all of the
scikit-learn it's the standard way of
computing computing the
mode essentially of your posterior
distribution and if you've got enough
data and your model is or your
distribution is well-behaved enough in
the limit the mean and the mode are the
same thing and that's really super great
so maximum likelihood estimation is a
fair way to go what you don't get with a
point estimate however is the standard
deviation you don't know your
uncertainty and that is why when you do
have the full Bayesian posterior
distribution and you know both your your
location your mean and the scale of the
variance you're going to be doing a
better job at the end of the day so that
is my talk questions oh and let's go -
thanks whoo thank you
thank-you pie ladies thank you women and
machine learning Thank You team Stan and
here are a whole bunch of references
that should answer all your questions
about using students okay
now let's have some questions yes hi
Stan is just released up to stand 2.19
and pie Stan by the way is GPL it is not
BSD licensed but Paiste on has a richer
set of features in terms of working in
python and getting your data in python
so commenced in if you if you use pi
standin and like pi stand please please
continue pi stan is there trying to go
to something different but the GPL thing
was actually a big deal for a lot of our
users the reason that command Stan PI is
in existence is a really nice guy and
in the University in Marseille put
together the first version of the
package which he called PI commenced in
and I basically took PI command stand
and it's now been completely rewritten
but it was definitely something that
needed to be done because everybody was
writing their own lightweight wrappers
to avoid the GPL problem yeah and but
the other thing is really that we we
want to be able to keep up with the
stand
releases transparently so it's that's a
software engineering problem you really
you really need to make your components
as as loosely coupled as possible
otherwise you've just got a maintenance
nightmare more questions yes you have to
know your data you have to know your
data and you have to know your
application you would that status is a
tool and yeah I mean if you could if you
could do the simplest possible model I
think you know Occam's razor says always
go for the simplest the decisions that
would affect that would be how expensive
is your data to collect and you know
whatever is going to be fastest and
cheapest is probably the answer but yeah
yes and there is there's a whole set of
package there's this in again these are
packages that exist mostly in the our
ecosystem for model checking and model
comparison so there's a package called
blue which is leave one out
l oo leave one out validation and yes
the the statisticians do have all of
these one number descriptions of how
well the model fits the data that's the
AIC or the W AIC are the D IC so you
would use the the packages and I think
Arvest has some of this cooked into it
to get your actual evaluation of how
well the model fits the data but yeah
they're there there's a whole workflow
that this is embedded in and we're
definitely trying to put it all together
so that people can just sit down and
know that these are the steps that you
have to do check them off the list you
know that you're doing good science
questions
it's been a long day huh
okay thank you very much
[Applause]